and finally new rule [ __ ] fees when did
the American business model switch from
honestly selling you a product who
tricking the consumer who doesn't read
the fine print late fees rebooking fees
restocking fees roaming fees overdraft
fees cancellation fees fees cuz you
forgot to say Simon Says my credit card
has a maintenance fee for what it's a
piece of plastic in my wallet
so like someone from Citibank comes by
once a month to water it
you ever wonder why is my cell phone
contract longer than a Stephen King
novel because it was written by
Rumplestiltskin if you forget to turn
off data roaming and you go to Vancouver
for the weekend
Verizon gets to keep your children this
is the new way we do business and it's
all based on the cynical premise of you
[ __ ] up that they can wear you down
confuse you or count on you to forget
take something as simple as gift cards
they look like an easy and convenient
way to say I wanted to buy you something
but I just barely give a [ __ ] but almost
a third of the people who received gift
cards never use them it's a bet between
you and Red Lobster that even when it's
free you still don't want to eat ready
same thing with gym memberships only 18
percent of Americans who join a gym wind
up actually using it the rest go twice a
year the way Catholics go to mass and
again it's a bet
between consumers of gym memberships who
were saying this is the year I get off
my ass and get in shape I know I can do
it and the owner of the gym who's saying
well I know you can't yell lazy loser
you'll come here three times in January
and then I'm done with you for the rest
of the year thanks for the free money
enjoy your hot pocket because in America
a [ __ ] up is our best customer credit
card companies are based wholly on that
premise that you the consumer wants
something now some crazy impulse
purchase like gas and you think you'll
be able to pay for it before the
interest kicks in and for people who
want to get screwed even harder than the
credit card companies do it oh yes
there's payday loans the average
interest rate they charge in Colorado is
a hundred and twenty nine percent if an
actual loan shark charged that much
you'd break his legs
and 129 percent is the low-end yeah tied
for second highest or South Dakota and
Wisconsin where it's okay to charge five
hundred and seventy four percent the
highest is Idaho where it's not even a
number they just cut out your organs and
sell them on eBay but hey don't worry
payday loan victims as soon as Trump
passes his tax reform
you'll be cashing your checks at a
casino and Monte Carlo
I'm kidding you'll be cashing them
outside a casino in a Monte Carlo
[Applause]
[Music]
now any discussion of fee [ __ ] a new
term I'm coining fee [ __ ] the
customer would be incomplete without
mentioning the airline's who are always
bitching about their costs you know the
price of jet fuel and unions and planes
as a justification for their fees you
know what if I want to hear a crying
baby you never shut up I'll fly your
shitty airline where you charge me a fee
for checking my luggage now and another
one if it weighs too much in a fee for
wanting to talk to a human on the phone
you want a blanket fee you want to fly
inside the plane fee if Sully landed on
the Hudson today they charge a life vest
fee
it can cost $200 just to change your
ticket multiply that by the number of
fuck-ups to hungover to make their
flight out of Vegas and you see how an
American now there's no margin for
[ __ ] up and that applies to one other
group a group which very much depends on
people [ __ ] up in order to stay in
business the Republican Party it's true
their whole game is making voting such a
hassle for the people they want to keep
out of the booth that those people just
give up and don't vote that's true
now is doing that criminal yes should we
have to jump through hoops to vote of
course not but life isn't always fair so
until it is just do it it's not
impossible especially if you're young
who vote the least and have the time if
you can stand in a line for a damn phone
you can stand in line to vote
[Applause]
[Music]
if you can find the after-party
you can find the polling place if you
have time to get a tattoo you have time
to get registered picture ID yeah it's a
pain in the ass when you take pictures
where the [ __ ] thing in your life is
selfie for democracy and just do it